Marcel we met Nora your on-screen
girlfriend we even got a kiss at the
dinner table so I'm wondering was that
your first onscreen kiss on screen yeah
on screen yeah yeah we got on screen it
was my first kiss so it was it was kind
of weird just because it's it's a dog
yeah differently you're doing not you
know just you and the person it's like
the whole crew and everyone like
hundreds of thousands of people watching
at home
Isabella day you were squealing with
laughter when I just asked Marcel that
question what is it like for you being
like his big sister on the show but also
in real life what is it like for you
watching all of this I think I'm Way
more stressed out than him it's so
uncomfortable it makes me one of the hi
Isabella hi Marcel how are you guys
doing it's so nice to see both of your
smiles and friendly faces it's a really
weird time I know we're all at home
staying safe but of course first of all
how we're both of you doing me I'm doing
good um it is after a while you start
going a little crazy I've been talking
with a couple of friends because if you
just you know don't talk to anyone or
stays alone at home you will go crazy
but I feel like we can all relate at
least we're all and you know in the same
place and we're all feeling the same way
all around the world so that's good to
feel that well in this together and well
yeah it's just sometimes it the days get
very repetitive it starts to like have
you hit the stir-crazy point almost I'm
trying to keep myself busy so I don't
hit that place okay and I'll ask you
what you're doing but Isabella first how
are you doing I'm okay I'm pretty okay
I'm an introvert so staying home with
nothing to do is kind of my dream but
that was kind of my downfall too is like
I came into something like oh it's gonna
be great because I I'm so good
this and it's been I'm almost to my
third week of it and so starting this
week my body was like oh boy and I'm so
sorry is this like our life now so now I
feel a little off but I'm working
through it the fact that you say you're
an introvert absolutely shocks me
because you're like a comedy god full of
life so it's funny like are you like a
homebody you're used to kind of like
nesting at home yeah and I mean inter
I'm an extrovert and introvert but it
means is I'm having human interaction
takes my energy away and so I come back
to myself and hang out by myself to like
reach hard towards an extrovert is
charged by being around people a
psychology Wiz as well so many these are
long days they're long days long hours
what are you doing to pass the time
wandering a lot of homework which is
what a lot of kids my age are doing so
that's a great way to pass the time it's
to that just because you know waking up
early when you don't really technically
have to no one's telling you to wake up
early it's you have to put yourself some
discipline and that's something that I
feel like all the kids my age a bad
thing - yeah and I mean apart from that
I'm trying to clean my room do do things
in my house that I don't get to do every
other thing what is your typical day
look like because I imagine you have a
set tutor when you're at work right yeah
so now your days really like a typical
high school student yeah I mean I'm I'm
used to getting in and out of public
school because I rather be going to
school than being at home just because I
like interacting with my friends and
socializing you know keeping that part
of like my childhood but yeah it's
usually that way I'm I'm very
independent but at the same time like I
need someone to take my phone away or or
or you know tell me oh you have this
dude tomorrow so that I actually do it
because if not it's like it's harder for
me
to force myself to to work but yeah I
tried to take breaks in between because
if you're too long staring at a screen
you start going crazy so I start I try
to do like an hour school and then half
an hour of like playing basketball and
then go back into it so are you are you
like skyping with teachers I just don't
know how I would ever teach myself like
algebra or science at home by so it was
hard enough for me physically being in a
room with a teacher so how is it that
you're you're managing all of this I'm
realizing now how stressful it is when
you when you explain it but well I've
gotten used to this season since we're I
mean we shoot while I'm in school I
cannot attend school so this semester
I'm doing it online so really even
though everyone's like in quarantine
online school still is doing the same
thing Isabella what are you doing at
home Queen nothing has heard or
professional life no I'm really um every
day is different but the same the only
thing that I'm telling myself that I
have to do is get my body moving at
least once a day that's great and that's
it because at first I felt a lot of
pressure because everybody kept being
like oh now that were a quarantine we're
gonna write our script and we're gonna
do this thing and we're gonna like learn
a new language and a new instrument and
I felt so overwhelmed I was like I can't
believe I have to come out of this thing
with an a whole new skill set like that
seems why it's named um but I I've been
very vocal about going to therapy and
and one of the things we've talked about
is people want to fall back into their
old patterns within their homes and this
new thing it's just kind of a trauma
response and so if your life is gogogo
people are trying to keep it that way
within their homes and for me I'm just
trying to let my body process this thing
that realistically is traumatic it's a
traumatic event that the world was going
through and I think a lot of people are
kind of like hazing out of it and being
like I'm just gonna
a new language and we'll see what
happens which is totally fair - but for
me it's been easier to let myself feel
my things work out once a day I've been
watching all the documentaries and all
the TV shows and all the movies I
stopped acting class so that gives me a
little bit of structure
wow you're busy I mean look you're are
you doing like Skype therapy session
still oh my god yeah
so you're skyping with your therapist
you're skyping with your acting class
are you skyping with a trainer are you
doing workouts virtually no I don't have
a trainer but I I do like online
workouts and I do that whole thing and
I've been working out more than ever
I'll be like it's my third hour of a
workout but I'm just gonna keep what
else do we have to do right nothing else
to do
these are the more sit-ups I know what
kind of workouts are you doing I'm
curious um it depends
I've been getting back into running
which is kind of a lot of runners
talking about it being a form of therapy
and of meditation because Turner's going
out so I'm doing that I like started
training a lot so I'll like do exercise
and medicine balls and jump rope and
whatever and I've been going on a ton of
walks and in the middle of my walk
there's stairs so I'll stop there and do
like 20 30 minutes of like going up and
down and then continue so that's kind of
been my jam and shredded during
quarantine
I mean I've also been eating all the
snacks so it's just really state one
balance okay my next question is there a
meal or a snack that is like your go to
right now that you feel like you're just
constantly preparing in the kitchen
honestly snacks Oreos and like a fast
food that you know it's easy to make
cassadee is can I ask flavor of Oreo
Double Stuf just you can't mess with the
regulars it always has to be double
stuff there's a whole new world out
there I can show you guys because there
are kinds of flavours you gotta try
lemon Oreos ah I feel like I'm such a
Latina I would eat
so much like beans and rice and like
either like ground turkey or ground beef
or chicken um and I've been trying to do
like granola and yogurt which is always
something that I like in theory I'm like
that stings really nice and now I have
time and it's available Marcel I'm
watching you on tick-tock you're
brilliant on tick-tock I want to know
how much fun are you having on tick-tock
and like what's the secret to making a
great video you hate that question I'm
not on tick-tock I haven't consumed I
but I just think it's so funny because
Marcel and I had a conversation before
this one I'm not really on I'm not I
don't really do not like compared to
like other people my age like like I'm
not like very consistent but I guess
like when I when I'll put out a video on
this channel but yeah I just started
like I mean when it became famous like a
couple months ago like everyone had it
besides me and like I saw my friends
doing videos it looks like so to be able
to relate to my friends in that way I
just downloaded and I guess now we're
pointing you have a lot of options to
use it I still haven't done too many but
but I'm gonna try to to make more what
like what goes through your mind when
you're like I'm gonna set up this
tick-tock and I'm gonna do this the
basketball one that you did was super
impressive was like I saw this guy doing
something like that so I like just got
inspiration from that and I was just in
my room bored I just did it yeah stuff
like that like it really comes out of
nowhere it's is for fun something that's
funny or something that's cool are you
gonna try to convince Isabella to make
an account while all this is still going
on what she's you're making account I
feel like she'd be great on zig zag I
feel like you would - why are you so
resistant
you're so funny you've got the biggest
personality in the world oh you know a
little renegade a little something see I
feel like people expect me to be like a
dancey tech talker and I can't I don't
it's not loki say it like those
businesses are not really like dance but
you can you can do it I see you wasn't
let's check it like maybe in two weeks
I'll be like guys follow me on texts huh
okay we'll stay tuned we're gonna keep
applying pressure Marcel a very
hard-hitting question for you do blondes
have more fun the last time I saw you
this blonde ooh was not there you worry
that's true I mean I feel like just
dyeing your hair you'll have more fun
yeah me personally I have never done my
hair in my life and I like my natural
hair color but at this age after a while
you can get a little bored in my 16
years of life now you see all these
people doing things with their looks and
having fun with it I mean is they should
do it and at the same time it's like you
could get a little bored after a while
so I mean it's like it's it's weird the
first couple of days I would wake up and
I forget I my hair was like this and I
just saw like white in front of my face
and I was like what is that but but it's
fun yeah it is really fun to play around
with
so was this it was this a work decision
was this for the character of Alex
Oh 5050 yeah I mean a lot of kids my age
are dyeing their hair or like I don't
know appears in the easier doing stuff
like that for fun and I wanted I wanted
to do it in real life anyways I was
going to do this color not like a pink
or something like that I loved when I
talked to the showrunners of one day at
a time like in Gloria we were you know
we were talking and I just said it like
I guess an option what a guy likes his
dices hair I mean that would be fun I
feel like is the age he would do it and
you know you see him the first couple
seasons caring so much advice look
I was a teenager it's like I don't care
let's see how this looks
yeah they loved the idea and we did it
so that was really fun to do that for
the show so is the blonde here to stay
do you think this will be like a
permanent look change for you I mean I'm
not gonna say permanent but maybe for a
little for a little while and I just I
just feel like after you dye your hair
you get addicted to it and just start
doing every color so we'll see I mean
it's such a nice base for other colors
because that their bill sticks so well
to that it'll be so nice what colors
next
I look you into pink Thanks I think
people would look so fierce oh my god
I'm so are you do you try that in
quarantine order a little boxes off
Amazon and Scott shot Gloria shot Mike
kool-aid I remember when I was like your
age I dyed my hair with kool-aid and
then that way you can just take it out
pretty easy yeah oh wow Mike Huck I made
you a profile of tinder says lonely
Catholic nurse seeks big strong man to
fill the hole in her life you might want
to reward that Isabella my question for
you is you know a lot of a lot of girls
and women especially are you know we're
missing our eyebrow appointments
people's roots are growing out I want to
know what is your beauty routine like in
quarantine and is there something you
cannot wait to make an appointment for
when this is all over I'm a bad girl
I rose done I have virgin hair I've
never dyed it my mother cuts my hair Wow
hmm I never really get my nails done
because Elena wouldn't like she sorry I
and I don't do my eyebrows well we do a
line I like I don't even pluck them at
all so I'm chilling about beauty at all
I know I think actually what's been my
routine is not doing anything like
getting to like not wear makeup and give
my hair a break and not do things to
anything is so nice and I've been the
only thing I've been doing is I've been
going crazy with the moisturizer on my
face and I started I tried toner for the
first time and I was like look at me
well you both look great from the waist
up but I want I want a moment of honesty
are their sweat pants below because in
the tiniest PJ shorts in like my rooms a
disaster I'm like this is incredible so
cool that you guys are dressed like so
well like I mean you guys should
me like 30 seconds before I joined thing
I was like where's the lid closet okay
okay go do you have like a quarantine
outfit that you guys have been living in
have you been getting ready at all some
people are wearing jeans I don't
understand that
what have you been wearing workout
outfits and sweat pants been wearing
sweat pants and just any t-shirt that I
go to sleep in the cozy life oh yes go
from the bed to the living room and
never change so I want to talk to you
guys about one day at a time
congratulations the fourth season is so
freakin good I didn't think it could get
better but it did I want to know how is
this whole pandemic affecting production
well we're not there and we don't know
when we'll be back which is so
unsettling and weird because normally I
mean we're kind of no strangers to it
because with the cancellation season 3
it was kind of the same thing where it
was like whoa maybe they will maybe they
won't but with this it's like who we're
airing now so we don't really know what
that's gonna look like but of course
it's necessary and especially you know
Rita and Norman they don't look at but
they're up there in years then we just
want to make sure everybody stays safe
how much are you missing being there
with the cast and the crew and I know
you guys are such a tight-knit family I
mean I feel like we're all feeling the
same way I where we're trying to tax as
much as possible every time there's a an
episode that airs we do a zoom live
while we're watching the episode which
is really cool that still feels like
we're together watching it especially we
were getting into the hang of it so well
we were in deep in to the season halfway
through and we were it was getting
better every week and and then now we
took this break it says it feels a
little weird and yeah we just want to be
back the seasons so great and it's been
so much fun to film has the group chat
been live yeah
[Music]
well what goes what goes on in those is
it trading means what you like what is
it that you guys are chatting about or
are you just kind of checking on each
other making sure everyone's happy and
safe yeah you know sometimes sharing
funny thoughts or stories and like you
know positivity - every episode that's
airing on Tuesdays and it for me it's
just the funniest thing is when Rita
texts tell me every time she writes like
by Rita mines every touch is a signature
like we know it's you you know but she's
the queen we could never tell her that I
will say it's also been really cool this
is the first time that us as a cast has
been on a network show so like texting
about like numbers and like all that
stuff the day after is so weird like
I've never had to do that before and
we're interesting to see like how we did
and like what does it mean for us and
like it's just getting to do episode by
episode is such a different thing and
there's so much information then on just
the episode and then we're getting to
life tweet so I'll do the zoom will real
text each other during and then we'll do
all these Instagram lives and like it's
been a really nice thing to look forward
to during quarantine I think one of the
coolest things about your writers room
is that they write about the most
topical things that are going on and I
think it's so awesome that you're now on
cable where the writers have sort of
this advantage where they can write as
they go as opposed to with the old
regime where they had to write a bunch
you shot a bunch and then you were done
so I'm wondering do you think there's a
chance that we will get a quarantine or
a coronavirus episode this season we did
a mini episode it was amazing yes so we
did that but I I would I guess it
depends when we go back but I would
assume because it's something that the
average family would definitely be
affected by so that was virtual school
today pretty much like this talking to
people I don't want to talk too out
papito Wow hey hey hey is that even in
time
I can already I reorganized my entire
closet I really wish I had more clothes
I'm going night
I can't imagine Schneider and that would
be living at each other in Cory night
he's driving each other nuts papito
going nuts in the corner of the room
just being irritated by everybody
millena educating everybody on witness
claiming every doorknob I'm like but
like had there been talks about an
episode maybe airing like that other
than from the mini episode which you did
know because that's the thing is we
don't know when we're going back and I
know Gloria has been vocal about this on
Twitter it's like we don't know what it
looks like to go back to work because
even the skeleton crew is I think around
60 people mm-hmm that's a ton of people
and no way we can stick 6 feet apart
from each other and we're all touching
each other so for actors we have 4
million people on us all the time or
groups that are going around it's just
there's a lot to have to avoid it's so
nice to meet all of you thank you for
taking me to dinner miss Alvarez oh well
it's not every day that Alex gets a new
girlfriend and even though that day was
four weeks ago it's nice to finally meet
you
Marcel we met Nora your on-screen
girlfriend that was a really fun and
delicious episode we even we even got a
kiss at the dinner table so I'm
wondering was that your first onscreen
kiss on screen yeah
on screen yeah yeah well yeah like I
don't know my mother who texted me like
after that episode and like yeah first
on speakers Congrats it's just like you
just didn't feel like like that like
such like a big I mean well acting it's
a professional I think you know where me
and Raquel who plays Nora were you know
very mature both the same age and like
in as actors I guess so so we know I
guess that's normal but yeah on screen
it was my first kiss it was it was kind
of weird just because it's it's a job
it's it's acting yeah listening you're
doing not you know
just you and the person is in front of
like the whole crew and everyone and
like hundreds of thousands of people
watching at home well I was gonna ask
did you watch with your family what did
the group chat say when the episode
aired reaction very quiet I just could
see like all the riders faces because I
had seen it already for me it was just
like the fans reactions to it was really
funny
just because already this whole season
they've been comparing like Alex from
now know like the height difference with
with Lydia and things like that I've
been really cool to see and now would
like the kids it's just something that
like they didn't expect to come already
in the second episode so it's a lot to
get used to it Isabella D you were
squealing with laughter when I just
asked Marcel that question what is it
like for you being like his big sister
on the show but also in real life what
is it like for you watching all of this
I think I'm Way more stressed out than
him it's so uncomfortable it makes me
wanna die why is it uncomfortable
because we're like family and I've known
this kid since he was 12 years old and
so it's just weird the dinner table and
like we're supposed to all clock it and
and kissing on-screen is very different
than kissing on camera I mean on in life
because a little bit for longer for it
to register so then it's like they're
making up for what in life feels like an
ungodly amount I didn't feel that way
like you were kissing for much longer
than you would have in real life but
yeah I felt longer than it was supposed
to be yeah like sometimes you're kissing
there and it's like you feel like it was
it was long enough for the camera to
register and it's like oh no we didn't
even see it
so like at 30 seconds to that and we're
like oh my god but at least I felt more
comfortable of having Isabel by my side
cause she had to kiss so many people
so when she knows how it feels bro that
was what like threw me to as I remember
my first onscreen kiss was with Froy
season 1 with Josh and we were 18 and I
remember us freaking out like we were
like this is the worst
so then seeing Marcela Merkel be so
shown they're like hey anyway yeah I was
like okay did you give him any advice
where Marcel did you go to Isabella for
any advice no I just kept being like hey
do you need to talk about it are you
okay are you comfortable and he's like
what do you mean we're just it is what
it is Marcel you are so chill and so
relaxed I have to know you know the
Internet has gone pretty nuts over you
in the last couple weeks like I don't
know if you've taken notice but the
comments on the interview we did
together on the set of the show everyone
is in love with you and thinks that
you're like this Teen Dream heartthrob
so I want to know how you're handling
this newfound heartthrob status I mean I
don't really like see it that way or see
that I I mean I'm very like grateful for
any support that I get and I know like
you know the fans of the show and my
fans are always supporting and a really
nice throughout all these years so I
mean I'm always very thankful for that
and I'm just always be myself to myself
and people like that that's awesome
Isabella the worst well I just like
here's the thing is marshmallow looks
super grown because he's grown up a lot
and he's super handsome and whatever but
sometimes people like people forget but
he's a child like a literal underage
child and so sometimes it's just really
stressful to see like teenage girls will
always be crazy and like I remember
being that way about
Justin Bieber whoever but then when it's
like adults making comments and adults
being weirdos and adults being lame is
also hot I'm like he doesn't even have
his license how about you chill out yeah
me to get my learner's permit yeah so
it's a little weird and it's also again
like he's like my baby brother and then
like and it Isabella for you it's the
opposite where everybody on YouTube is
absolutely floored by the fact that
you're 22 everybody thinks that you're
16 and I saw you Raquel justice actually
thought that you were turning 16 yeah
when you were working together I mean
what do you make of all of those
hilarious comparisons you know for a
long time I'll be working for a long
time I'm gonna be 30 working with a team
cast which makes me a little nervous I
mean girl get that coin can't be yes you
know it's fine I've always had a baby
face can I just let you off here maybe
you stop first Marcel I am I'm just
doing my job here I'm a woman of the
people the people of the Internet know
that Alex is happy in love they want to
know if Marcel is happy in love hey I'm
just gonna say that the record even
makes it 10 times harder to be happy I
don't know I like a lot of people it's
not a very beautiful souls as one
captured your heart
I mean ah I'm not seeing them there's no
one like I'm really like talking to it
on that like I'm not I don't have a
girlfriend right now
okay he's single ladies and especially
now that I'm that I'm you know when
you're working on one date I'm not go to
school that's really work at this age
where you can you know how the
relationship or something like that but
yeah I mean in the past
there has been people I liked and now I
mean there is a lot of people that I
need that I really get along with so
anyway
seeing what I'm trying to say is that if
you can talk to someone if you can get
someone you know to talk to that
conversations about relate to it's a
good idea um still of that generation
that like Bening from their start grew
up with a phone in their face or things
like that so I you know I I like to meet
people in person and I and I'd like to
you know have conversations and yeah hey
Queen Isabella same question for you Oh
admirers as well I'm just so focused on
like now I'm gonna call myself like who
are you talking to
during quarantine that I haven't heard
about um you know what he said
quarantine is hard
I mean being so young and being in the
spotlight is dating hard yeah La La's a
hard place to meet people I would mean
in the spotlight is it's just harder
just because I I don't know but I feel
like maybe it's it's harder for people
to get to know your your true self maybe
they already think that they know you
but they really don't at the end of the
day so it's it's more about yeah you're
just getting to meet someone in in a
real way you know not because you heard
something about them or see them on TV
what is it that you're both looking for
in another partner in another human
being I think I think a sense of humor
somebody that's easy to talk to um and
somebody that has good intentions and a
good heart I that I think is what's
hardest to find in LA hey would you be
the same thing your celebrity crush
about these things because technically
we could meet them oh and then you would
thank me for playing cupid between the
two of you god I feel like lately
everybody in my life is there trying to
play cupid
I just watched Zac Efron's hot ones
interview
I was a big High School Musical fan and
I was like ah I yes yes Zack go off I'll
do in the name but but I feel like this
is like my former celebrity crush okay
Emily when I cause I interviewed her
last year she did an amazing horror
movie with Aaron Paul you should watch
it she was really good she's gorgeous
next thing you know we're eating
Lunchables in separate rooms and grand
mama lives in a home I think the other
big thing that fans of one-day-at-a-time
really love is that you guys Isabella
and Marcel you're not only siblings
on-screen you very much feel like you're
family off screen so I would love if you
could just talk about your relationship
a little what you love most about one
another what annoys you about one
another and just like the magic between
the two of you and your friendship
yes Marcel what do you love most about
me I love most about Sevilla you know
everything on said she's just putting a
smile on everyone's face she's hugging
people even if they don't want to hug
she's just very positive she's great to
be around it's you know you need that
energy when you're when you're filming a
scene or especially in a comedy show you
need to have energy and and it's great
to really feel like a family because we
can joke around and not be nervous
always really all over the place oh that
was sweet
he's never said anything nice about me
before this no I love that week have
like this gives to me like a real
sibling relationship and especially as a
AG guy and like we both got older
obviously I feel very much like mother
hen and that I'm like with the work l7m
I'm always like hey what's up do you
need me do need anything do you want to
talk about anything my door is always
open if he's like yeah dude I'm good but
thanks look okay I love you have a good
day and he's like okay it feels very
true to what it is but Marcel's such a
cool 16 year old which I try not to
him often but he's just like funny and
charming and like super talented
genuinely which a lot of 16 year-olds in
this industry and so it's I'm saying I'm
just saying he's he has a lot of great
qualities to him which is really cool
especially to watch him grow into them
that's the first nice thing she says
about me that's a lie
[Music]